welcome to the weekly play this is the
weekly play pre-show in a little bit
we're gonna get actually into the show
so right now we're just kind of shooting
this [ __ ] but benny is away and we
decided that for this week we're gonna
be talking about e3 and everything that
came out of it so yeah that's that's
quite literally the basis of the podcast
um as you guys know in the last podcast
that we have we were talking about
dabbling in anime maybe having an anime
podcast or having like a gaming podcast
so this is really just us dipping our
toe in the water this is just kind of
getting a sampling of this is this is
the beta the beta of this pot
and then the next week and next week i
think we said we'd have the first anime
podcast so
what
what oh yeah we did didn't we i didn't
hear about that it was literally decided
about half an hour ago it was like it
was it was literally like heroes here
was literally the decision
like tiffany here's how it went down
you guys could do the anime podcast next
week okay
yeah that was that was the
decision-making process for the anime
podcast
that was the brainstorming i like that
i like that level of decision making i'm
comfortable with that because i know
across the internet we all work
basically the same thing like i got an
idea for a show should do that show yeah
okay
okay so so jumping into the into the
podcast proper um the first game i
wanted to talk about the one that i that
really really got me psyched are we
still doing the pre-show are we doing
the podcast we're doing the podcast now
because that was kind of like the
introduction to the podcast so i said it
was the pre-show when i said it we
didn't introduce who we are this is like
the most dysfunctional star trek podcast
hey everybody welcome to the weekly play
our beta of doing a gaming podcast on
the weekly pull channel essentially um
this week we're going to be talking
about e3 what's been going on what games
we like what we didn't like who had good
shows whatever we decided to talk about
but it's all gaming today i gotta tell
you guys
with us today we've got rob as you
obviously all know say hi rob
cool i have a really bad habit of
chewing on my nails like it's such a bad
habit i know i shouldn't rip it over you
fast i'm sorry my man and we have joel
of course joining us today and i'm
tiffany from comic pop so
let's get into this let's get into this
so
the first game okay so so when i was
going through and looking at the
trailers the first the game that that
actually was the first game i saw and
this one that's like stuck with me the
entire time is the last guardian so i
took a look at it like i looked at the
instruments i didn't think it was going
to happen i looked up the information
and they're like okay
it's not officially tied into uh eco or
the um
or the shadow of colossus that game is
somehow tied into those games there's no
way you can make a game that looks that
way that plays that way and functions
that way and is not tied into all into
to ico or shadow of the clock there's no
way
i think it is like just expand even if
it's not expanding that story i think it
is expanding that universe at the very
least um or at least that sort of world
i i we don't know much about it yet but
um
we didn't know that uh shadow of the
colossus was actually connected to aiko
until like the very end yeah until the
very end but no i mean it's it's
i mean as soon as i saw it like as soon
as they fired up the trailer in the game
play i was like
this looks like like because my thought
was okay are they remaking shadow of the
colossus or are they doing like some
kind of blend because i mean let me tell
you something right now man if
playstation came out and they said hey
guys look like were we making shadow of
the colossus for the ps4 dude i'd buy
that game so fast and make your head
spin like i'd run to gamestop and be
like give me that game where people will
get hurt like well they already
did technically release it on the ps3 so
i think it's gonna be a while before you
probably see a remake of of that oh yeah
and we did see a lot of remakes and
re-releases yeah we did
okay so there's a phrase in the uk
called butt clenching trailer
um
really
the last guardian was just a clinching
trailer because like the amount of times
it looked like it was gonna die my butt
was just like
that's my fear with it too i don't want
any bad things to happen to the bird dog
if any bad things happen to the burned
dog i'll be upset
it's good griffin let's call it we'll
just call it a griffin it dave i think
it's a bird it's a bird dog
it's a it's a dog it's a dog that's like
part bird like i mean
like it's i'm going to call a bird dog
like okay
everybody gets a trap it gets it gets
even more complex when you find out they
actually based it off a cat instead of
at least at one point
everybody in the chat who has twitter
from this day forward we here at the
weekly play or yeah the weekly play are
laying down the law
and saying that this creature whatever
its name may be and whatever the the
official like nomenclature a big word
there whatever the the official
terminology may be for what this
creature is
it will henceforth be referred to as a
bird dog
okay well
it could be a blog if you will like it's
as soon as i and that's that's like
that's what's so crushing about those
games because you get so emotionally
invested like when i played shadow of
the colossus like i got so emotionally
invested with the character i was like
oh my god like he basically released
like a demon at the end of the game and
now he's like a bad guy that's what you
think of the emotional attachment to my
emotional statute was i had this
incredible sense of guilt killing these
colossus
by the end that like just wore on me to
the point they weren't hurting nobody
they were minding their own business
exactly i didn't feel bad about killing
the colossi until like at the end of the
game and i was like oh my god we were
killing gate they were just doing their
job
like oh my god
the thing that made me feel bad
was the horse
that was the time i felt bad because i
was like oh no let's be honest any time
there's a horse or a dog
you know it's not you know i mean i
learned that lesson when i saw the
never-ending story and falcore died and
i was like
pets are not safe
malcor don't you mean
actually the reader and the watcher's
sadness that killed our tax
yeah i always felt that way myself i was
like
i was like wow way to pin it on me no
you know what no
like somebody on reddit posted the idea
they were like hey guys here's an idea
and people were like what they were like
what if peter pan was really like an
angel and all the kids who were going to
neverland were like kids that were dead
wow all right and i was like okay
that crushes my childhood in its
entirety like that destroys everything i
thought i knew but no like that's i mean
we know that that thing's going to die
and it's going to be sad when it does
and we're going to cry but you know
that's the thing they've said that it's
not going to die like that
say that if you knew that everyone
assumed that you're like no but i got to
keep some semblance of you hooked into
this somehow so i'm sure you've heard
the joke because this was delayed it
come out like a bunch of e3s ago and
it's just coming back now the joke
flying around the internet was when
everyone on twitter said oh no that
thing's gonna die and like oh crap they
figured us out we gotta go back and
remake the whole thing no no no no let's
kill the kid instead yeah look at it or
you get reformed
yeah like it's it's less sad when you
get reborn because you're like okay cool
they came back but then like when
they're dead and like they're gone and
they're never coming back and it's just
like oh my god
like that's it it's the most
traumatizing experience your tears will
bring dead pikachu back to life only
your tears only the power of your tears
why would you remind me of that that was
like
but no like like you know in all
seriousness the game looks gorgeous i
mean it looks it
does it's stylish it fits in with the
world that they created i appreciated
the fact that the director was there you
know at least the idea
it's got the iconic run of all of those
games
yeah it does and that was a cool thing
because i guess the kind of transition
here you know once when i finished uh
when i finished that trailer i moved on
to horizon and horizon looks like it has
a cool story but i think that that one
of the biggest problems i think a lot of
people are going to face is with the
next gen consoles coming out with the
ps4 relatively new with the xbox
relatively new people are like okay we
want high-end graphics we want the best
bang for our buck we want you know
console graphics that are relatively
able to uh to compete with pc not truly
but can do decent enough
and so i think there's gonna be i mean
that's what horizon horizon looked like
it was focused on graphics the gameplay
looks good and it looks like a cross
between like tomb raider and assassin's
creed but the game looks like it's it's
pretty functional it's just for me when
you look at story versus
appearance versus like graphics i'll
take story any day of the week and so
that's why you know when you look at um
when you look at at the last guardian
wall it looks a little like vintage in
terms of how everything is kind of sharp
around the edges and it's not nearly as
smooth and so on and you know it's it
plays smoother it looks like it plays
smoothly it looks it looks gorgeous so i
think that's going to be the the big
thing and they have an art style too
they're not trying to hump your eyes
with graphics they're actually like we
have a style we're going for like
telltale
horizon is from the devs of killzone so
you know sony's gonna be pushing this no
matter what and we might just be seeing
them taking the graphics out for a test
drive there might be more to this than
we know but sony always strikes me as
the company who is more about the flash
in the pan and then the rest of the
information kind of comes afterwards
like look at this incredible game we
have there's a female protagonist you
know what i mean like was she voiced by
actually
birch did her voice
maybe i'm crazy i don't know
someone look into that
well
what i think we need to keep in mind
though is that this is e3 and anything
shown at e3 that doesn't have like a set
release date that's in like two months
is subject to change oh yeah um
especially like in graphical quality
just look at the division everybody no
yeah
well no i mean it's like like last um
last
year good infamous second sun is another
example which i
if they're e3 where it was announced
they're like yeah it's 1080p 60fps and
then it came out 720p 30fps maximum if
you're lucky maybe you got 25. yeah it
was it's the new math a year of e3 minus
graphical quality equals what it's gonna
look like when it's released no i mean
that that's that's that's the big kicker
that's really kind of the funny thing is
is like last year when they released or
i guess when they had the gameplay demo
that infamously crashed on the ps4 um
assassins creed black flag
you know like i mean obviously they made
changes they changed the functionality
of the game made some tweaks and
different things like that and that's
why it's kind of the kicker is because
at any point in time like anything can
change games could be pushed back a year
i mean we talked about that earlier with
the division you know things can be
pushed back by a huge margin a huge
amount of time because there's all kinds
of things to tweak and you know it may
be i mean you would hope
that they would test the game before
they actually like went to e3 and said
hey let's play this on the ps4 i mean
you know i guess maybe black flag kind
of changed that let's also not forget
about the fact that there's a difference
between the developers coming out and
giving you an estimation of when the
game is going to be coming out and the
like sony or microsoft or nintendo even
coming out and saying when the game is
going to come out because they want a
date that's going to get people hooked
in the devs are going to be like yeah we
could do that but probably not we need
more time you know so like there's
definitely a difference between those
two types of dates you're gonna get and
i definitely think it depends on how
finished the game is because if the
game's close to finished the devs just
want it out they want to move on with
their lives or as the publishers like
wait till christmas of in three years
time it's always christmas it's always
christmas oh yeah christmas is the bane
i mean that's exactly what happened with
the night to the old republic too when
obsidian was building that game they
were like this game is going to be huge
and it's going to be incredible and
lucas arch was like we need to set by
christmas and obsidian was like there's
no way to finish this game and have it
out by christmas and they were like well
do something like wish upon a star juice
like work like work you know 16 hour
days do something and make it happen
sacrifice some blood to your blood god
yeah
and the game was incomplete and people
were just like this sucks so speaking of
games that we've had to wait a long time
for because i know the chat wants us to
talk about this um kingdom hearts three
yes we've been waiting for this for like
10 years now
no haven't we you haven't enjoyed all
these spin-off kingdom hearts on other
like every other console i i love that
we now need a flow chart to understand
what the story of kingdom hearts is
because it's like you gotta get your
phone and your ds and your psp and
everything you're not a fan of that what
and i love like when because i'm big
into kingdom hearts because i've been
with it since the beginning i'm not
giving up now oh yeah but when people
tell me oh what's the story of kingdom
hearts where do i get started and i'm
like how much time you got buddy yeah
just just don't try
like i'm more than happy to stand in
front of a camera trying to explain 60
70 years of comics kingdom hearts no no
no no no
the ds1 they brought in time travel and
now everything is just everywhere so
well no i mean like okay
watching like the the reveal watching
the like the trailer and so on what i
will say this
what i will say is this is that the the
opening sequence assuming that's the
opening scene where the two of them are
talking that pales in comparison to the
opening sequence to um to kingdom hearts
ii the one where like mickey shows up at
the end and he's got like the keyblade
in his hand and all that you guys
remember what i'm talking about oh yeah
yeah yeah like that was that was
probably one of the greatest like
sequences in the history of like video
gaming in general like i've watched that
so many times when it first came out i
was like this is
crazy
but not like like the kingdom heart
series i think is long overdue for a
god for some kind of like fresh breath
into it because in truth it's like the
assassin's creed series if all you get
are expansions to the existing games
like people are just going to get so
tired and they're going to want
something new they're going to want
something fresh and i'm fingers crossed
because i'm going to buy this game when
it comes out i'm really hoping we get
that but fafsa if you want to if you
want to mention it you made a really
good point earlier before we launched a
podcast where you talked about what
you'd seen in the trailer
oh they've added in rapunzel's world
which you know it's all interesting and
stuff from tangled right yeah
it probably won't be in the final game
because let's be honest we in kingdom
hearts 2 we saw woody and buzz we were
promised woody and buzz
we didn't
you're probably right i mean and the
fact that the game has taken so long and
now affords them opportunities to add
things in that they might not have had
beforehand now star wars or marvel
exactly that's what they've actually
said um as soon as uh disney acquired
both marvel and lucas arts they were
just like well we've got all this other
stuff getting postponed again and
but that's a that's a really good reason
for them to possibly take out tangled
because they're like well
do you think that people want to see
tangle or do you think they want to see
like you know all the characters on half
um
they're clearly going to put frozen in
there like it's disney's biggest cash
cow it'll be the plant will be half
frozen and half hoth and they'll just
you know what's gonna happen like you're
gonna be running through the world of
frozen and there's gonna be like an
instrumental like epic japanese musical
version of like let it go
of course
under the sea levels where it's like hey
here's the dance dance revolution plan
well because we're the weekly play this
week aren't we yes we're the weekly play
the weekly is that the name is it
official
we're talking about video games in this
podcast what's going on people as you
guys know benny's not here because we
had benny killed off he
was
saying things that people didn't like
and so we hired a man we hired the
faceless men of braavos
to kill benny and so benny's no longer
with us
vinnie will not be joining us for the
rest of his life having said that
we're excited
tiffany will be taking vinnie's place
for the duration of forever i am
i mean that means that joel is taking
sal's place
it's getting weird this is good am i
taking rob's place no
you are promoted to rob
whoa
oh man yes the weekly poll is the is the
game of thrones of podcasts we
systematically have people removed
when we do not agree with them that's
right yep it's okay because we'll
rebuild them as giant zombies so it's
fine
the white walkers looking forward to
that new york comic-con is going to be
interesting with a giant benny zombie
yes i guess
i'm gonna come back am i the only one
around here who really really wants to
see
like the white walkers just lay waste
to like everything
considering how evil everyone is in
westeros why not why not just like wipe
out westeros and leave it at that
my favorite part of game of thrones this
season is that woman that literally just
had one word said over and over
it's
have we explained what's happening this
week no yes we have yes we have there's
like there's like
two groups of people that i want to see
die that i want to see like the white
walkers kill i want to leave everybody
else alone i want them to keep everybody
else alive but i want to see them kill
like everybody in westeros like the
lannisters including jamie lannister
because i haven't forgotten that [ __ ]
all right
yeah
and i want to see them like kill those
people kill like the guys of the night
watch that like stab jon snow those guys
are pretty those those are the guys like
those guys are dicks like i want to see
those guys die and then especially ollie
ollie's the worst you little punk he
took you in he loved you and respected
you and you quite literally stick the
knife in them yes like jon snow
scratches all he's back all he stabs him
in his like how crappy could that be
like that's just
not cool
jamie lannister is not redeemed much as
people hate darcy i really like her
i i really like cersei as a character
oh yeah and i was just
yeah i kind of want to be as
manipulative as cersei but not [ __ ] at
it oh my god
i feel like i don't know you anymore
hang on great real quick guys i just
want everybody to know that welcome to
the weekly play this is the weekly play
pre-show in a little bit we're gonna get
actually into the show so right now
we're just kind of shooting this [ __ ]
but benny is away and we decided that
for this week we're gonna be talking
about e3 and everything that came out of
it so yeah that's that's quite literally
the basis of the podcast um as you guys
know in the last podcast that we have we
were talking about dabbling in anime
maybe having an anime podcast or having
like a gaming podcast so this is really
just us dipping our toe in the water
this is just kind of getting a sampling
of this is this is the beta the beta
and then the next week and next week i
think we said we'd have the first anime
podcast so
what
what oh yeah we did didn't we i didn't
hear about that it was literally decided
about half an hour was like it was it
was literally like he was here was
literally the decision
like
tiffany here's how it went down
you guys could do the anime podcast next
week okay
that was that was the decision making
process for the anime podcast
i like that
like that level of decision making i'm
comfortable with that okay because i
know across the internet we all work
basically the same thing like i got an
idea for a show should do that show yeah
okay went up okay so so jumping into the
into the podcast proper um the first
game i wanted to talk about the one that
i that really really got me psyched are
we still doing the pre-show are we doing
the podcast we're doing the podcast now
because that was kind of like the
introduction to the podcast so i said it
was the pre-show when i said it we
didn't introduce who we are this is like
the most dysfunctional star trek
hey everybody welcome to the weekly play
our beta of doing a gaming podcast on
the weekly pull channel essentially um
this week we're going to be talking
about e3 what's been going on what games
we like what we didn't like who had good
shows whatever we decided to talk about
but it's all gaming today i gotta tell
you guys
with us today we've got rob as you
obviously all know say hi rob
cool we gotta have a really bad habit of
chewing on my nails like it's such a bad
habit i know i shouldn't rip it over you
fast i'm sorry my man and we have joel
of course joining us today and i'm
tiffany from comic pop so
let's get into this let's get into this
so
the first game okay so so when i was
going through and looking at the
trailers the first the game that that
actually was the first game i saw and
this one that's like stuck with me the
entire time is the last guardian so i
took a look at it like i looked up the
information
i didn't think was going to happen i
looked up the information and they're
like okay it's not officially tied into
uh eco or the um
or uh the shadow of colossus that game
is somehow tied into those games there's
no way you can make a game that looks
that way that plays that way and
functions that way and is not tied into
all into echo or shadow of the clock
there's no way
i think it is like just expand even if
it's not expanding that story i think it
is expanding that universe at the very
least um or at least that sort of world
i i we don't know much about it yet but
um
we didn't know that uh shadow of the
colossus was actually connected to ico
until like at the very end yeah until
the very end but no i mean it's it's
i mean as soon as i saw it like as soon
as they fired up the trailer in the
gameplay i was like
this looks like like because my thought
was okay are they remaking shadow of the
colossus or are they doing like some
kind of blend because i mean let me tell
you something right now man if
playstation came out and they said hey
guys look like were we making shadow of
the colossus for the ps4 dude i'd buy
that game so fast and make your head
spin like i'd i'd run to gamestop and be
like give me that game where people will
get hurt like well they already
did technically release it on the ps3 so
i think it's going to be a while before
you probably see a remake of of that oh
yeah and we did see a lot of remakes and
re-releases yeah we did
yeah we did
okay so there's a phrase in the uk
called butt clenching trailer
um
really
the last guardian was just a clinching
trailer because like the amount of times
it looked like it was gonna die my butt
was just like
that's my fear with it too i don't want
any bad things to happen to the bird dog
if any bad things happen to the burned
dog i'll be upset
it's good griffin let's call it we'll
just call it a griffin
i think it's a bird dog it's a bird dog
it's a dog it's a dog that's like part
bird like i mean like it's i'm going to
call a bird dog like okay
every everybody gets a trap it gets it
gets even more complex when you find out
they actually based it off a cat instead
of a dog i could say that like a big cat
you mean like yeah lion kind of
yeah like a lion
it powered at least at one point
everybody in the chat who has twitter
from this day forward we hear at the
weekly play or yeah the weekly play are
laying down the law
in saying that this creature whatever
its name may be and whatever the the
official like nomenclature a big word
there whatever the the official
terminology may be for what this
creature is it will henceforth be
referred to as a bird dog okay well
it could be a blog if you will like it's
as soon as i and that's that's like
that's what's so crushing about those
games because you get so emotionally
invested like when i played shadow of
the colossus like i got so emotionally
invested with the character i was like
oh my god like he basically released
like a demon at the end of the game and
now he's like a bad guy that's what you
think of the emotional attachment to my
emotional statute was i had this
incredible sense of guilt killing these
colossus
by the end that like just wore on me to
the point they weren't hurting nobody
they were minding their own business
exactly i didn't feel bad about killing
the colossi until like at the end of the
game and i was like oh my god we were
killing gate they were just doing their
job
like oh my god the thing that made me
feel bad
was the horse
that was the time i felt bad because i
was like oh no let's be honest any time
there's a horse or a dog
you know it's not you know i mean i
learned that lesson when i saw the never
ending story
and falcore died and i was like
pets are not safe
now don't you mean um what the hell is
the horse no no no no no no no no our
tax yeah yeah attack
swamp of sorrow all right hang on i'm
gonna try not to get us off on a on a
tangent here but i do want to mention
that i just read something recently i
read it where somebody had an
interesting hypothesis about our tax and
how it was actually the reader and the
watchers
sadness that killed our tax yeah i
always felt that way myself i was like
i was like wow way to pin it on me no
you know what no
you're bad
like somebody on reddit posted the idea
they were like hey guys here's an idea
and people were like what they were like
what if peter pan was really like an
angel and all the kids who were going to
neverland were like kids that were dead
wow all right and i was like okay
crushes my childhood in its entirety
like that destroys everything i thought
i knew but no like that's i mean we know
that that thing's going to die and it's
going to be sad when it does and we're
going to cry but you know that's the
thing they've said that it's not going
to die like that what did you
say that if you knew that everyone
assumed that you're like no but i got to
keep some semblance of you hooked into
this somehow so i'm sure you've heard
the joke because this was delayed it
come out like a bunch of e3s ago and
it's just coming back now the joke
flying around the internet was when
everyone on twitter said oh no that
thing's gonna die and like oh crap they
figured us out we gotta go back and
remake the whole thing no no no no let's
kill the kid instead yeah that'll get it
or you get reborn i don't know how you
went
yeah like it's it's less sad when you
get reborn because you're like okay cool
they came back but then like when
they're dead and like they're gone and
they're never coming back and it's just
like oh my god
like that's it it's the most
traumatizing experience your tears will
bring dead pikachu back to life only
your tears only the power of your why
would you remind me of that that was
like
but no like like you know in all
seriousness the game looks gorgeous i
mean it looks
stylish
it fits in with the world that they
created i appreciated the fact that the
director was there you know at least
it's got the iconic run of all of those
games
yeah it does and that was a cool thing
because i guess the kind of transition
here you know once when i finished when
i finished that trailer i moved on to
horizon and horizon looks like it has a
cool story but i think that one of the
biggest problems i think a lot of people
are gonna face is with the next gen
consoles coming out with the ps4
relatively new with the xbox relatively
new people are like okay we want
high-end graphics we want the best bang
for our buck we want you know console
graphics that are relatively able to uh
to compete with pc not truly but can do
decent enough
and so i think there's gonna be i mean
that's what horizon horizon looked like
it was focused on graphics the gameplay
looks good and it looks like a cross
between like tomb raider and assassin's
creed but the game looks like it's it's
pretty functional it's just for me when
you look at story versus
appearance versus like graphics i'll
take story any day of the week and so
that's why you know when you look at um
when you look at at the last guardian
wall it looks a little like vintage in
terms of how everything is kind of sharp
around the edges and it's not nearly as
smooth and so on and you know it's it
plays smoother it looks like it plays
smoothly it looks it looks gorgeous so i
think that's going to be the the big
thing and they have an art style too
they're not trying to hump your eyes
with graphics they're actually like we
have a style we're going for like
telltale has a style horizon is from the
devs of killzone so you know sony's
gonna be pushing this no matter what and
we might just be seeing them taking the
graphics out for a test drive there
might be more to this than we know but
sony always strikes me as the company
who's more about the flash in the pan
and then the rest of the information
kind of comes afterwards like look at
this incredible game we have there's a
female protagonist you know what i mean
like was she voiced by actually
birch did her voice
maybe i'm crazy don't know
someone look into that well
what i think we need to keep in mind
though is that this is e3 and anything
shown at e3 that doesn't have like a set
release date that's in like two months
is subject to change oh yeah um
especially like in graphical quality
just look at the division everybody no
yeah
well no i mean it's like like
last year they brought in
good infamous second son is another
example which i if they're e3 where it
was announced so like yeah it's 1080p
60fps and then it came out 720p 30fps
maximum if you're lucky maybe you got
25. yeah
it's the new math a year of e3
minus graphical quality equals what it's
going to look like when it's released no
i mean that that's that's that's the big
kicker that's really kind of the funny
thing is is like last year when they
released uh i guess when they had the
gameplay demo that infamously crashed on
the ps4 um assassins creed black flag
you know like i mean obviously they made
changes they changed the functionality
of the game made some tweaks and
different things like that and that's
why it's kind of the kicker is because
at any point in time like anything can
change games could be pushed back a year
i mean we talked about that earlier with
the division you know things can be
pushed back by a huge margin a huge
amount of time because there's all kinds
of things to tweak and you know it may
be i mean you would hope
that they would test the game before
they actually like went to e3 and said
hey let's play this on the ps4 i mean
you know i guess maybe
black flag kind of changed that let's
also not forget about the fact that
there's a difference between the
developers coming out and giving you an
estimation of when the game is going to
be coming out and the like sony or
microsoft or nintendo even coming out
and saying when the game is going to
come out because they want a date that's
going to get people hooked in the devs
are going to be like yeah we could do
that but probably not we need more time
you know so like there's definitely a
difference between those two types of
dates you're going to get and i
definitely think it depends on how
finished the game is because if the
game's close to finish the devs just
want it out they want to move on with
their lives whereas the publishers like
wait till christmas of in three years
time it's always christmas it's always
christmas oh yeah christmas was the bane
i mean that's exactly what happened with
uh night to the old republic too when
obsidian was building that game they
were like this game is going to be huge
and it's going to be incredible and
lucasarts was like we need to start by
christmas and obsidian was like there's
no way to finish this game and have it
out by christmas and they were like well
do something like wish upon a star juice
like work like work you know 16 hour
days do something and make it happen
sacrifice some blood to your blood god
yeah
and the game was incomplete and people
were just like this sucks
so speaking of games that we've had to
wait a long time for because i know the
chat wants us to talk about this um
kingdom hearts 3.
we've been waiting for this for like 10
years now 11. have you been you haven't
enjoyed all these spin-off kingdom
hearts on other
i love that we now need a flow chart to
understand what the story of kingdom
hearts is because it's like you got to
get your phone and your ds and your psp
and everything you're not a fan of that
what and i love like when because i'm
big into kingdom hearts because i've
been with it since the beginning i'm not
giving up now oh yeah but when people
tell me oh what's the story of kingdom
hearts where do i get started and i'm
like how much time you got buddy yeah
just don't try
like i'm more than happy to stand in
front of a camera trying to explain 60
70 years of comics kingdom hearts no no
no no you use the ds1 they brought in
time travel and now everything is just
everywhere so well no i mean like okay
watching like the the reveal watching
the like the trailer and so on what i
will say this
what i will say is this is that the the
opening sequence assuming that's the
opening scene where the two of them are
talking
that pales in comparison to the opening
sequence to um to kingdom hearts 2 the
one where like mickey shows up at the
end and he's got like the keyblade in
his hand and all that you guys remember
what i'm talking about oh yeah yeah yeah
like that was that was probably one of
the greatest like sequences in the
history of like video gaming in general
like i watched that so many times when
it first came out i was like this is
crazy
but not like like the kingdom heart
series i think is long overdue for a
god for some kind of like fresh breath
into it because in truth it's like the
assassin's creed series if all you get
are expansions to the existing games
like people are just going to get so
tired and they're going to want
something new they're going to want
something fresh and i'm fingers crossed
because i'm going to i'm going to buy
this game when it comes out i'm really
hoping we get that but fafsa if you want
to if you want to mention it you made a
really good point earlier before we
launched a podcast where you talked
about what you'd seen in the trailer
oh they've added in rapunzel's world
which you know it's all interesting and
stuff from tangled right yeah
it probably won't be in the final game
because let's be honest we in kingdom
hearts 2 we saw woody and buzz we were
promised woody and buzz
we didn't
we didn't see them
you're probably right i mean and the
fact that the game has taken so long and
now affords them opportunities to add
things in that they might not have had
beforehand now star wars or marvel
exactly that's what they've actually
said um as soon as uh disney acquired
both marvel and lucasarts they were just
like well we've got all this other stuff
getting postponed again and which is
what but that's a that's a really good
reason for them to possibly take out
tangled because they're like well do you
think that people want to see tangle or
do you think they want to see like you
know all the characters on half um
they're clearly going to put frozen in
there like it's disney's biggest cash
cow it'll be the plan will be half
frozen and half hoth and they'll
just and you know what's going to happen
like you're going to be running through
the world of frozen and there's going to
be like an instrumental like epic
japanese musical version of like let it
go of course there's gonna be i'm just
gonna suddenly turn into a rhythm game
where you have to like mash buttons to
your like those little mermaid under the
sea levels where it's like hey here's
the dance dance revolution planet where
you just got to hit all the buttons but
the songs are so catchy though
um while we're talking about kingdom
hearts can we talk really quick i don't
know if anybody else watched it i
watched it today um
square enix's um you say no
square enix's conference and it made me
so [ __ ] sad because sony had already
announced everything other than kingdom
hearts three and it made it hurt me it
like really hurt me because
there was disrespect to all the people
in that audience for not cheering or
clapping for at least the individuals
who were up there to talk about the
games it was just it was death it was
absolute death because everyone was like
saw that saw that saw that saw that you
know what sony why don't you get your
own [ __ ] and put it out there and just
stop making all of the announcements
like pick one of the square enix games
that you're going to have but you're not
even having them exclusively you know
like it's just ps4 first
sir yeah
because they knew there was just one
trailer they needed that if they had it
they could win the hearts and minds of
everybody and i think you know okay that
is
let's just talk about this i don't care
about final fantasy 7 anymore i do oh my
god
okay dude let me tell you something man
let me tell you something man let me
let's have this conversation my friends
back in the day let's go on an adventure
once upon it once upon a time there was
a little rob and little rob had played
final fantasy games for years and years
and then suddenly he had a playstation
and square back in the day with
squaresoft squaresoft said
we're launching final fantasy vii
and rob got the game final fantasy vii
and you know what the game turned out to
be it turned out to be one of the
greatest
rpg games
ever made in the history of rpg games i
was so excited and so for me even if
it's only going to be remastered even if
it's basically going to be like the
final fantasy version of the last of us
remastered where they say everything's
the same except the graphics look better
i don't care i will go out i will buy it
and i will play it because to me the
final like final fantasy 7 is the best
final fantasy game of all time i mean
you got sephiroth you got cloud
they've been chasing forever to their
own
now let me tell you about chibi faust or
feta spouse whatever you want to call
him
i like the first one better
no i know i know what chippy fast means
because i remember like reading about
dragon ball z back in the day
and they were talking about like chibi
trunks i was like oh so that's like the
little trunks so it's okay so you're
talking about like little fellas you
just take faust's head and put on a
little tiny body
that was essentially me when i was young
i've looked like this for about 20 years
so let me tell you about chubby faust
chibi faust played final fantasy 7 went
that's a good game and promptly moved on
with his life
well and then final fantasy
and final fantasy 9 came out and chibi
faust was like this is the best game
ever oh oh
like everybody skips eight everybody
skips squall where it's just like yeah
that didn't even happen yeah there was
no final fantasy it just went from like
seven to nine it was weird
yeah but like final fantasy nine the
square was like yeah this is gonna be a
revolutionary final fantasy it's gonna
be the one we're banking on they put a
lot of time into it it's got an amazing
story like if people say that final
fantasy 7 has a better story than final
fantasy 9 i'm like you're wrong
you're wrong
everyone's going to have a favorite
final fantasy minus 10 but i'm not going
to defend it to the grave i got my hd
redo of it so i understand the
excitement of fans of seven finally
getting this because square was really
very much like i don't want to do that
because it's a lot of work like it's a
lot of work they're like a lot of money
playing a lot but they had an hd yeah it
wasn't like an hd remake like they're
doing now but it was remastered into hd
um i think some attention to the other
classic final fantasies is worth like
just their time
no
you know what that means point though
but don't forget your dollars
will tell them what you like and let's
say final fantasy vii the remake sells
[ __ ] crazy right and it will and it
will
other people are gonna be like i want to
see a remake of this and if you get
enough people voicing that like they did
with seven you might see that because
they might be like hmm all right that
did pretty good well no no even the
smallest drops of water can erode
yeah that's why i'm a bit like okay
maybe because nine is the second best
selling final fantasy on the playstation
network store uh on the ps3 at least so
if a behind seven um so i'm i think if
seven's rema remake does well
nine will get its moment in the
spotlight again
let me tell the story of a little
shinjul of a little violent real joel
i'm trying to use my japanese words
here's the thing i actually came really
late to final fantasy if you can believe
like i came super late like i played
chrono cross before i played final
fantasy
i know so to me this day's still uh it's
going to be another chrono game soon
right
right okay
did you ever ever play like a chrono
trigger on the super nintendo chrono
trigger was was the tits back in the day
but no like okay i understand where
you're coming from fast like i i get
what you're saying i mean i will admit
there is there's a great deal of hype
and some of it may be artificial maybe
unnecessary around final fantasy vii but
for me when it comes to final fantasy
games they've been around for so long i
mean i mean we were talking about this
earlier they've been around since the
nintendo and we've played them since the
nintendo since like the original version
so like we've seen like the super
nintendo versions and all that kind of
good stuff you know as the series has
progressed
for me i think that final fantasy games
whichever one people pick up first is
going to be their favorite and final
fantasy vii when it came out like that
was at a time where you just had this
mass influx of rpg games that were just
exploding onto the scene and final
fantasy was leading the way because
they've been doing it for so long and so
when when squaresoft came out and
launched that game there were so many
people that got final fantasy 7 they
said oh my god no game's ever going to
be better than this
and so some i can guarantee you will
never ever go back and buy any final
fantasy games because they'll say none
of these games are ever going to be as
good as seven i'm not like that i played
final fantasy 13 and i played 13-2 which
are the only two games i've played
besides final fantasy vii 13 was decent
13-2 was amazing so
you know i mean it was really kind of up
in the air on on what it is that people
dig but i love final oh hold on no now
wait a minute i got part way through
thirteen and it really lost me are you
sure i've see i think final corridor was
really interesting in the sense that
whatever the other one was that's really
what it was it got a little too
repetitive which is really bizarre to
say about a final fantasy game because
you go into that knowing this is going
to be repetitive and that was corridor
my my thing was like final fantasy 10
was done linear but you had moments
where you stopped to breathe and you're
in a town and you got to just explore
and chat to npcs that was gone in final
fantasy 13. oh yeah and um the story
just fell a little bit so final fantasy
occasionally has games where it borders
on sci-fi and classic fantasy um but it
just felt a little bit too sci-fi and as
much as they have said well with going
fantasy is in what you your imagination
is no if it fantasies in the title i
kind of want more fantasy than sci-fi
i'm going to be honest
um okay i don't think no oh no no now
wait a minute
all right you got a few more minutes
this is becoming the final fantasy chat
i i disagree
i thought the story of okay final
fantasy xiii lacked the the romance and
the ambiance and the whole thing the
whole feel of final fantasy 7 and even
final fantasy 9 i'll give you that you
know because i've played that a little
bit but not nearly as extensive as any
of the other ones
i will say this though
i thought between the way the game
looked between the way the game played
between the overall story the idea of
developing powers and there being kind
of a caveat like a catch that if they
didn't carry out the task that was
bestowed to them that was never really
told to them that they had to figure out
they would turn like these zombie
creatures well it seemed a little
far-fetched and it did kind of seem like
a john carpenter novel
that in the end like it was still pretty
solid and i i still thought it was
i wouldn't say one of the best final
fantasy games i've released
but i would say i would say a solid
contender for a really good final
fantasy game
well like it felt a little bit selfish
if you compare it to a lot of the other
final fantasies because you can't really
say like it's it's
this is the only one where they've got
something personal at stake because all
the other ones it's like if we don't do
this our whole world is dead and we're
dead so they made two sequels just
seemed a little psychotic on final
fantasy's prize i was like if you don't
like it we're gonna make you like it
love it by the end and then they had so
much respect for the fan base of final
fantasy 14 where they said okay no one
likes this let's retract it and then
just do this most people don't like
final fantasy 13 they're like you will
like this have another sequel
i love lightning's hair
lots of action figures with her just
real quick i'm gonna i'm gonna do a
quick rundown of the some of the sony
announcements from their conference just
so just we just stuff we covered stuff
we haven't covered uh they talked about
the last guardian they talked about
horizon they talked about the new hitman
anybody
that almost completely ignores the
hitman from before they're like look
we're starting over again
you know they're coming out with this
because they're coming out with a movie
you know and it just happens to look
like it's kind of a good game too so
yay 1847 held his gun sideways what was
up with that
gangster it's gangster 47. like
47 is his name okay so here was a deal
about about the hitman series so i
played hitman 1 played hitman silent
assassin
and then i think i played hitman
whatever whatever the newer one was
absolutely yeah absolutely it was kind
of a forgettable game
uh hitman silent assassin i think was
the best one they made so far like that
game was was so fun and it was so good
having said that all by this i mean if
they're effectively rebooting the hitman
series which we don't know if they
really are or not i mean because at the
end of the trailer she says it's good to
have you back so it's not like i mean
well it's not either telling us like
he's coming handler was killed in the
other one so the fact that she's talking
to him exactly so it's like okay
where exactly does this say because
here's here's what we we don't know
exactly what they're doing they could be
completely getting rid of the last game
and saying this takes place before that
game and that game doesn't exist or
probably again they're probably trying
to make a connection to the upcoming
movie you know what i mean like they're
just you know going to do some
continuity changes i bet like you know
what i mean like just a little fact that
it's just called hitman makes me think
reboot yeah you know like games that are
based off of movies or connected to
movies that as a rule since platformers
haven't been a thing they're just not
good that was going to be
even when they're playing platformers
let's all face it the super mario super
mario bros movie not good stop it the
aladdin game from back in the day okay
there's exceptions to the rule it's yeah
it's
yeah you can't really take a video game
and make it into a movie so i'm really
hoping the hitman movie does well um
same thing for i'm sure some of us heard
this is on the list too the assassin's
creed syndicate um and that assassin's
creed they're moving forward with that
movie guys no okay let me tell you
something about this dude man
assassin's creed one was one of the
coolest games i played because it was so
new and free running an assassin's creed
ii built on top of that
it was one of my favorite sequels yeah
and then you know what assassin's creed
became assassin's creed became a man
on life support that they just won't let
die like it's it's call of duty they
need to come up with a new one every
year
okay one like we've been sitting on the
edge of our she's wondering okay when is
this end of the earth event supposed to
happen and all that kind of stuff
they keep pushing it back like that was
supposed to be the big thing on
assassin's creed 3 at least i thought it
was because after playing brotherhood
and revelations i was like oh my god
let's just get to the damn game they
came out with assassin's creed 3 and
like this is going to be the biggest
assassin's creed game to date this is
going to be amazing it's going to be
awesome i'm like awesome we get to see
how everything ends we get to see the
end of the world maybe they'll all like
survive maybe they'll die will the
assassins beat the templars and it's
just like to be continued and i was like
oh my god really dude did the end of the
world event will happen when everybody
stops buying assassins
that's exactly what it is
for anyone who doesn't know assassin's
creed syndicate is essentially set in
the 1860s in england so it's oliver
twist in my opinion
and also with gangs of new york because
you're a raw english gangster
can i be honest about something i played
all the assassin's creed games up to
assassin's creed 3 and i did not like
any of them i've stopped giving them my
money it's totally fair
it's i get for me personally i like
again there's got a story that just
it
envelops me and i'm just like go i'm
rooting for all of you just go and then
assassin's creed i'm just like
so who should i care about here the guy
in
now or the past guy because that stuff's
already happened no it's right it's it's
and they further make money
yeah these and they further muddy the
waters in the whole like templar
assassin feud where they'll come up with
a game like rogue which rogue was
awesome rogue was better than unity to
have a thing where it's like ah but you
know the templars aren't so bad you know
they got their own thing going around
they're a little sympathetic to like
well now i don't want to root for anyone
because now you all seem like you're
fighting the same battles with the same
tools now what's the difference between
assassin ruler templar rule and and in
this game we'll all be rooting for the
street urchins so okay moving on
we have a street fighter five
dreams
yeah it's another street fighter game uh
dreams which is from um media molecule
who did little big planet it's uh
they're not really sure what it is and
they admitted that they have this i i
felt like that's the best kind of game
no i
because it's like a game or it's not a
game i don't know so i can't see people
using that by drawing dicks i know right
just giant dicks
but it could be cool um there's a new
destiny dlc that's going to be coming
out yes i am i am nice i am so psyched
about that by the way anybody if you
guys are listening um
i want to do like a raid tonight so send
me messages on ps4 marvel explained okay
let's continue all right um firewatch
okay
i'm actually on the fence about
firewatch um but firewatch looks cool
but it also has the potential to be one
of the worst games to come out
because i mean i forgot firewatch what
was that one again firewatch is the one
where apparently like there's this i
guess you're a mountain ranger i'm not
really sure
but like there's some girls that came
missing and
yeah it's it looks like it could be
really really good um
i kind of feel like team fortress art
style yeah yes i kind of feel like the
game's going trying to go for like a
toss-up between like the storytelling of
maybe like the walking dead minus the
zombies but with the same kind of
progression you know the slow progress
as the story moves on you learn more and
more um and it's kind of that between
like you know a first person
sort of game um
the game could be really good if it were
open world
if it were just this huge thing and it
has kind of like an la and water feel to
it where you're going around collecting
clues figuring stuff out that'd be kind
of a cool concept
it could be
like
disastrous
in my opinion if it's a linear game
because if it's a linear game that means
there's no real replay value to it
there's no real exploration going on
what bugs me is i can basically already
see the twist coming where it's like oh
you're up here all by yourself in the
mountains oh well i don't talk to the
other uh tower guys as much as i talk to
she's not real the late the lady on the
recorder she she's not really he crazy
he probably kidnapped them girls it was
him
that would be i've never seen this movie
yeah it was called a hide and seek
that'd be the most disappointing
ending to a to like a game if they did
that i would be i would get a shyamalan
twist at the end
it got funded in less than 12 hours
what
it had like 100 000 in 20 minutes i was
watching it they crashed the site i was
like i completely like i was reading
that word and i was like i know that
word
yes it was a game it was a game for the
dreamcast it took forever to be right
i'm tempted to just fund it and like to
make to it myself because uh what i
think the 100 one is you get your name
in the credits of the game like i'm
gonna be in a game
i thought this was yeah of scummy and i
talked about this with the control
breakers which is the video game arm of
comic book cast and it's whoa wait sony
so you're telling me i have to pay to
get this game made for the right to pay
for it again it's only later did i find
out this dude was doing the kickstarter
anyway
sony just gave him a platform to talk
about i was gonna say uh are we talking
about sony then yes
yes i mean dude let me let me say i'm
i'm really
really excited to see what they do and
as far as i understand they're bringing
back the entire creative team from the
first two games it's insane so imagine
imagine not having that job for 10 years
and then sort of like getting a phone
call one day and saying hey you're hired
i
can you imagine know learning curve
they're not currently working on games
now like trying to develop
this older game for this brand new tech
like
this is going to be interesting and i
really hope that we can no i'm scared
don't be scared
no i'm i think i think it's let me
when shinmu first came out it was it was
such a great game because it was so
different i mean yeah you have but it
was it was so expansive or i guess not
really expansive it was so immersive i
guess is the best way to put it and i
mean i remember just getting like so
swept up like i know i should stop this
i know i'm going to get like an hour of
sleep before i have to get up for school
but like i really want to play i really
want to see what happens and so it was
it was it was like playing metal gear
solid it just got so immersive you know
when i played it and
in truth if i mean with the original
creative team coming back assuming
they're going to be able to create a
story that's just as effective as the
first game second game was pretty it was
still pretty solid
i think that this is probably going to
prove to be one of the best games to
come out this year probably one of the
best games we're going to see for quite
some time to be honest but i could be so
i wonder if i wonder if it'll start a
precedent too now every e3 is one
company going to pick a kickstarter
project they really like and they'll get
to come up on stage and people are going
to throw money at it as hard as they can
because if so
yeah
they're only if they're like continuing
old games that were amazing
but that's that is the thing with like a
lot of kickstarter since then mighty
number nine kickstarter it has been
lately
yeah like hey we have our developer
development team that worked on a
previous game and we're making a new
game
funded in 12 hours yeah and every time
we're surprised for some reason hey hey
rob
can you adjust the name of this stream
because everybody had thinks it's still
the pre-show because it says oh it's
still the oh oops
i can assure everybody this is in fact
the podcast yeah
our beta test of
our video game podcast for the weekly
poll um and right now we're just going
through some of the games that sony
talked about um we just talked about
shenmue so let's move on not to see any
more yakuza because i love shenmue and i
love the spiritual successor to shenmue
which is yakuza but i'm finally getting
here again yeah right it's come it's
coming around um let's talk about uh no
man's story anybody see that that very
um open world galaxy exploring sort of
no man's sky no man's sky star i wrote
story no i haven't i didn't get a chance
to see that one okay so give me the
wrong thing
i know i got a
development a friend of ours who works
on like little indie games um was super
excited about the potential that this
game has and it's getting a lot of buzz
because oh yeah how expansive it is and
you know uh you know ethan as you could
imagine said no there's no way that
that's a universe sized
it is the size of the actual observable
universe so if you want to travel from
one side to the next you're going to
have to wait like five billion years
yeah so like
look like there's just one question is
it as expansive as minecraft because
that's really expensive it looks to be
close it looks to be kind of in the
ballpark yeah and they claim that every
point of light that you see is a sun or
a stone essentially so i don't know it
really could be anything at this point
we'll see if they can actually deliver
on this that demo was the one demo to me
that actually looked real because one of
the problems with e3 if you've been
watching them forever like we have a lot
of them are fake and scripted and
sometimes they get actual real famous
voice actors to pretend to be chatting
and hope we don't know
but no man's sky i know right no man's
sky actually looked real to me and it
answered a question that i always ask in
a game like this when do i get the
freaking gun and apparently you do get a
gun and you can destroy every planet and
i'm like awesome i can be galactus now
there you go
there you go that's awesome joel
destroyer of worlds hey joe have you
discovered anything i've been too busy
destroying all these planets
i stole all their knowledge then
destroyed the planet so no new knowledge
could be created it's brilliant um also
one of the big things that people were
calling like one of the mic drop moments
was the fact that if you're a call of
duty fan um black ops 3 ps4 players are
going to be getting first access to all
the dlc no man i don't care about call
of duty i used to and then i play it but
it's not going to make me run out that's
not the reason i'm going to run out and
buy a ps4 the thing that blew me away
is fps first time ever co-op during the
campaign you can now have a full co-op
squad which like it took you this long
to finally do this oh you guys have
friends who come to your house
people don't play video game in each
other's houses anymore that's what we
got really you want to play with them
cooperatively
no okay
man i i okay back in the day i used to
play call of duty all the time like me
and they uh me and a friend of mine ryan
we used to play all the time and we used
to do competitive like game battles and
stuff and we got really really hard into
it and then we just got so burned out we
were just like we walked away from it
like he went to go play world of
warcraft and i started talking about
comic books and that's it and so
i don't care about the new car all right
that's fair enough um like a couple
other things is uncharted 4 a thief's
end yeah that demo had a little bit of
an issue a little hiccup yeah
standing simulator it was amazing i was
like what the hell happened what is
something nope let's we'll just start it
again we'll just keep waiting for them
to tell us stuff where it's like now if
you look uh drake he's leaning in such a
way you can see the sweat pool on the
back of his back it's new technology um
it looks it's an uncharted game it's
action it's adventure it's shooting it's
driving it's it's
what it is they love it and you get
another one i mean i mean i'll check it
out i'll probably get it and play it
because i love those kind of games like
far cry uncharted so like i love those
kind of games yeah you're gonna you're
gonna still be on board for this yeah
and there's somewhere the tomb raider
people cried tears where it's like it
looks so much better than ours
like no but ours has boobs okay
it's different
ours has snow yeah we did snow in the
last one damn it look we did snow in the
first one too i'm one of the tomb raider
people
poor tomb raider and then kind of the
last thing hardware wise for sony was
the fact that they're offering tv now
you can
buy certain channels and if you're
already not hbo what not no not hp yeah
but it's all the channels you want you
can have i mean hbo is offering hbo go
as a standalone thing i think starting
next year anyway so
hbo but now they're going to offer hbo
go where you can just get that and not
have to have hbo well that's that's cool
that is very cool it took them forever
and a ton of people going to him being
like why haven't you gotten on board
with this yet you're losing so much
money stop being stupid it was probably
game of thrones that made them do it
of course and the wire and all that if
you're a plus
member in the playstation network and
you have a ps4 you'll get a discount on
your channels and that's all they really
said about that so who knows i mean i'll
check it out and see what it's worth
like whenever a games company talks
about having tv shows in a games console
i just go back to e3 was it three years
ago now it was just xbox's tv tv yeah
okay yeah i mean look at least if
they're offering the channel directly
it's not gonna host your tv cable um but
let's face it sony is famous for um
giving another company crap and then
taking that idea years later and yeah so
anyway um
let's move on to microsoft's um
really quickly halo 5. we got some more
details on that
uh fallout 4 we saw from them but we've
already seen it anyway i mean everyone's
like all right it looks awesome open
world man cool let me tell you something
itself all over that yeah exactly
exactly let's let's back pedal for a
second let's back pedal for a second you
know before we get it before we move too
fast halo 5.
so
what were your thoughts on halo 4 i'm
kind of curious did you guys play it
i
haven't had no skin in this fight oh i
haven't played a halo game i'll be
honest
wow okay halo halo 4
the halo 4 was cool halo 4 was a great
way it was 343 studios did a good job it
felt kind of short it was shorter in
comparison to the other it was it felt
like halo 2 in terms of like the length
of the game but it was still pretty
solid it was a good effort it was a
great way for them to establish whether
or not they could make a good halo game
and they could they made a great halo
game like it was very entertaining i
enjoyed it new characters new guns new
elements different things like that and
it still had to kind of tie in a little
bit to what was going on with the
previous uh halo series and the games
and or i'm sorry the the humans and so
on and so forth that being said
halo 5 i'm interested in seeing but i'm
only interested in seeing because of
what the story has to offer it's one of
these perfect examples where the the how
the game looks the graphics don't matter
to me don't don't really do anything for
me because there's so many games coming
out with amazing graphics
so similar like they yeah there's only
so much you can do to improve the
graphics on that kind of armor you know
what i mean like
it's even greener now yeah exactly it's
got a bit of shine
lasers have more pew than ever before
rob i gotta ask i thought the reason you
were gonna say you were into halo 5 was
because nathan fillion is returning
that's pretty good
that's that's cool but i've never
understood the whole hype around nathan
phil he was on firefly
yeah
he's a charming handsome fellow sir i
mean he's entertaining and he's he's
he's got his wit and he's funny and he
was great in firefly but i mean that's
like i'm i'm in video games for the
story i'm not in it for the voice actors
so sorry nathan philly
his face is there they rendered his face
my whole thing about like voice actors
in general in video games is
the voice acting is always better when
they hire like actual voice actors so
when they say this guy from this tv show
is in it i'm like cool do they have a
history and voiceover because those guys
that do voice over
like i used to do it it's hard the guys
that specialize it are the best in the
industry i absolutely agree with you um
i will say that when they had conan
o'brien and andy richter in to do voices
for halo that was hilarious so
but only because they're comedians not
because they're trained voice actors
because they're comedians um like greg
proops in a mad world is another example
of a really funny comedian doing really
well in a game there you go
um okay um recore that was something i
haven't been talking about fallout 4.
are you serious we're just going to skip
over fallout 4. well you you wanted to
talk about halo 5 and then you didn't
mention fallout i said i said let's i
said let's backpedal oh okay
fallout 4
everybody show in so freaking i don't
care what people are saying about the
graphics i am so in let's not forget
everybody fall off four apparently we'll
be launching a week before battlefront
but battlefront already shot itself in
the foot kind of amongst the fans so oh
my god what
hey ea here's a really good idea let's
take everything that made battlefront 2
awesome
and remove it but we can fist bump rob
now we can fist
you know what's going to happen like
like all that stuff that they took out
is going to come back with dlc but
nonetheless we're not going to get we
won't get before yeah fallout 4. follow
us
i am i'm very very excited he was my
biggest concern about fallout 4. i think
i think that that bethesda actually
corrected this very very early on when
they were talking about creating fallout
4. i think one of the big concerns that
people had is they said oh my god this
is going to feel like skyrim and they
immediately came out and said nope this
game is going to be totally different
the menu system is going to be different
it's going to feel like fallout 3 but
it's going to feel like a more amped up
version
of fallout 3 and after looking at the
the gameplay reveal and like just how
great the game looks and how immersive
it seems to be everything's customizable
now everything is it looks like what
they did is they took the best of new
vegas what little there was and they
took the best of fallout 3 and they
basically merged it all into one game
and then threw it to us and handed it
like gave us some more customizable
options i mean it's kind of weird that
they gave you such extreme
customizability with regards to the face
of the character when you're probably
never going to look at his face anyway
they're going to make a bunch of
freakish mutants in that yeah
people love that and they love to be
able to slap that on the box you know
they really do i mean people i'm one of
those people that will buy a game if i
can spend six hours in character
customization people it's it's like
people are gonna make like morgan
freeman people are gonna make hermione
granger like i want to make tom cruise
when i get myself
so like people are gonna make all
different versions of characters
but it's not the same like it's not
quite the same and not as many people
may not pick it up you know what i mean
like
people's parents will buy this
kid's parents would be like play this
i'm kind of curious to see how this is
going to play out because it's it's cool
to see
a lot of game a lot of game production
companies
taking like retro games and remaking
them and bringing them back for the
newer consoles and so it's fun to like
sit down and to see you know to ask the
question how would the current like okay
like uh like fried chicken you know
maybe that made the common f-zero what
would it be like if we saw some game
companies recreate like maximum carnage
recreate f-zero recreate like
recreate like ridge racer type four i
mean take some of these really old games
so these old school games that were
really cool for the playstation for the
the xbox when they first came out you
know for the super nintendo you know and
so on and the nintendo 64 especially
like turok the dinosaur hunter and bring
them back for like
no they don't they don't need to make a
neutral they need to just remaster the
old yeah just take one of the tour i
could take rage wars and i could play
with daniel and kill each other and
finally finish that game um i i believe
it's called ark is the new tura game
let's be honest if anyone's going to do
it it will be nintendo um a couple of
other announcements it was more
information really for some of these uh
hyrule warriors is going to be available
on 3ds they're redoing the game just for
the 3ds so if you like dynasty warriors
as well to pick it up um we got some
more what the one thing i did was
wondering about the new hyrule warriors
game is they didn't specify if it's
going to be new nintendo 3ds only like
the new xenoblade game that's a really
good point um but they did make sure to
let you know that there's going to be
new content for it from zelda wind waker
so as like an incentive to want to go
and get that they've had a steady stream
of content for that uh for that game
yeah did they i've always wondered about
this did they re-release wind waker on
like the wii yes they did yes they okay
it was hd and i've even got the special
edition wii u for it
i need to get a wii u and get wind waker
because that game was so good
daniel's
she hates the look of that game so much
really like the self-hating and all that
yeah she hates i love that like that
i could i can hear her like like as
you're talking about it i bet she was
just cringing
we also got some more information about
yoshi's woolly world i'm really excited
about that um i enjoyed the kirby
version of that essentially and this is
like a a
sequel to yoshi's story essentially and
i'm excited about that as well because
yoshi is such a cute character and i've
got a thing about cute games
it is it is an adorable game did you see
the the woman talking about it how she
went home and crocheted
yoshi's to show them what it would look
like yeah to help i just like to say
wooly world
that's why i love nintendo games because
i mean you got xbox and you got call of
duty battlefield so on you got the same
thing for playstation 4 and you got you
know battlefront and so on with nintendo
you just have like fun games yeah
they're just like fun
yeah like nintendo's good for me because
my scope of gaming is really just jrpgs
life sims platformers
i got all of that on nintendo yeah
nintendo's like they made it for fast
they like called you up and they're like
hey what do you want on this thing this
time around and you're like these things
they're like got it
they're the elder statesmen of all the
game developers and they're the last one
that's an actual game company not a game
arm of a massive faceless corporation
it absolutely is true and they you've
been seeing them today talking um
because let's not forget about the fact
that uh it is mario's 30th anniversary
this year seeing them talking about that
the pride that they have in that they
pulled out their old graph sheets
because they were talking about of
course super mario maker which is an
exciting game that's coming out it's not
really even a game it's just something
mario yeah yeah so
okay so what's the basis behind this
then you make mario levels and you can
use all different graphics from all the
different games and it's your
opportunity to make all the games or all
the levels you wanted to ever see you
know what's going on
with mario you know what's gonna happen
there's gonna be there's gonna be some
kid in like south korea or it's going to
be that one guy that has a record for
super mario world and they're going to
make the most ridiculous
levels absolutely like
0.00001
of like the 0.1 percent of mario players
can actually compete you're like but
that's okay because you can make your
own and that's what's so cool about it
and again like today when they're
talking about it they broke out their
graph paper they're like this is how we
used to make mario levels then we'd give
it over to the uh to the programmers um
so we got to see some really cool early
mario concept art um
and then i
one thing i'd like to see is street pass
um like if you pass someone who's also
played super
mario maker like you can play their
levels i'd like to see that would be
awesome nintendo get on that um
we saw a whole bunch of amiibo stuff um
ryu or ryu however you want to say it
from street fighter is going to be in
smash brothers that was kind of a pseudo
e3 announcement um but it leaked
beforehand i mean yeah so much from this
e3 leaked i wasn't surprised by anything
i was happy but i wasn't surprised i
know um and a couple of new games
announced from nintendo um for the 3ds
legend of zelda four swords it's going
to be this crazy co-op zelda game uh try
sword try search i wrote down four
whatever yeah it's a sequel to four
swords yeah
but you have to play with your friends
yes which is interesting because they're
forcing you to be friendly um
how very nintendo of them yeah exactly
they're forcing you to know people who
likes people what do you mean i can't
just kill them um i can accidentally
kill them probably um where you get to
have like different power-ups different
costumes that let you do different
things better than
you could do otherwise like you dress up
like a bomb person and throw bombs you
know they got they got rid of the purple
link though
i'm sorry
there's a i don't know man how dare they
do such a thing worst game ever i'm
gonna bomb their metacritic score
because there's no purple link
like a whole bunch of accounts
we saw metroid prime uh
federation force looks like i wrote down
here you know i'm on the fence about
metroid prime you know i played metroid
prime one great game played metroid
prime two better game and then just
didn't really get into metroid after
that this one is a again it's another
play with your friends kind of game it
you know it has like a weird ratchet
kind of vibe but not really but the last
time they did that i think it was
metroid prime hunters on the 3ds that
was
actually a really fun game yeah i was
watching the gameplay for it i was like
i want to try this i want to play this
with my friends like it was really like
it was fairly it looked tactical like
they the group that was playing it had
to go out and hunt these giant beasts
and like they try to be tactical and
people were jerks and they just did
whatever they want but it looked
interesting i think it's just more or
less it takes place in the metroid
universe yeah
um we also saw an animal crossing game
but i'm not
i'm sorry there's animal crossing board
game that looks kind of like um mario
party and um
and it's got a bunch of animal crossing
amiibos yes and and i'm gonna get them
all there you go someone tries getting
them for me i will stab them
the other thing about yoshi's woolly
world is if you have amiibos they're
working on it so if you put an amiibo on
your wii u yoshi will take on the skin
of that so like his yard would look like
whatever character you put on there yeah
and there was also the animal crossing
happy home academy game where you can
literally customize everything we're
gonna lose faust when that comes out for
like a couple of months but i'm just
making sure he's eating it
hey guys i'm not gonna be able to make
the podcast for like the rest of the
year so sorry i gotta i gotta customize
my town needs me
i am the mayor
um now just some other random things
that came out not even random because
they're not random they're big news um
we had uh we heard about rainbow six
siege another
and then we also heard about ghost recon
whoa i was shocked by that one i was not
expecting to be a new ghost recon and it
looks crazy it does it really does that
really came out of nowhere like oh
you're still doing really
yeah well see that was that was because
i remember they released what was it um
what was it they just released a ghost
recon maybe like three three four years
ago i think
maybe two or three years ago or was that
a different game there was there was one
that released around the same time as
battlefield
and the new the new car yeah around the
same time as battlefield 3 i think all
these war games blend together yeah they
they're all they're all pretty much the
same but
um before we go too far off of nintendo
oh i'm sorry
um someone just tweeted at me what do we
all think of the lack of pokemon news
um well if the pokemon news wasn't we're
making pokemon snap for the wii u i
don't care
who knows exactly what in the world is
going on tiffany is on spot
pokemon
pokemon snap and pokemon tournament need
to come back
yeah just do it just do it nintendo
my whole thing is we've all been
expecting pokemon z since pokemon x and
y and
no news at all um no battle i where's
pokemon z nintendo they got to invent
new pokemon they're sitting there in the
lab right now okay
this is the merged version of pokemon x
y they just need to add in about three
new areas and and it's set in paris so
just that the paris catacombs done and
i don't
either there's into it either there's
zero reason for it or there's an
incredibly good reason for it when it
comes to nintendo
yeah pokemon stadium there we go thank
you i was sitting here trying to think
well it wasn't called pokemon tournament
there is a sequel to pokemon stadium
there's two they're called pokemon
colosseum they're on the nintendo thank
you yeah it's not on the wii u version
of these things let me use my wii u mode
as my camera and pokemon snap just let
me do it oh that's good that's good
okay oh
bringing it down um we also saw mirror's
edge catalyst everyone's really super
excited about that you know i played the
first mirror's edge
i didn't get into it not a park or fan
hardcore first person i'm not
in first person i wasn't yeah i wasn't a
huge fan i was like this is it's it
moved too fast and it just seemed too
complicated for me god help you if you
get motion sickness playing that okay
yeah
what are they gonna do is they gotta
pair this new mirror's edge up with the
oculus
now having having said that the game
looked beautiful and the movements and
the mechanics were amazing i mean it
just wasn't the game for me but it was
it was an amazing game so
i was happy to see it back you know i
thought that was really cool so you know
i like seeing i like seeing female
protagonists so let's be honest there's
a lot of female protagonists i know
it's a really diverse show just like not
only just in the types of games because
there was lots of different kids but
diverse people who got to come up and
talk about their games right yeah yeah
it was it was kind of it was it was a
nice e3
it's very easy to harp on all the
negativity in the gamer community and in
games in general here's a nice thing
let's talk about nice exactly
um now let's talk about the star wars
battlefront
one on gameplay might be jakku we don't
i did not see that when i only saw hoth
and like that i was like yay at least i
could play with my friend i guess like
that's cool but boy do i miss like
classes so in all honesty like you know
all all joking aside and everything i'm
really disappointed with the game that
they're making you know what it felt
like
it felt like they said we want to make a
battlefront game
but we really don't want to have to make
a new game from scratch so let's just
like reskin battlefield
yeah i i got that it felt very modern
day fps like i felt like this this feels
like the mods i've seen for call of duty
so you can play as stormtroopers that's
that's exactly how it felt and it's
disappointing you know it's the problem
here is is what made battlefront so cool
it was so immersive you had you could
basically like be part of these huge
epic battles in the star wars universe
and they stripped that out they took
they took what made the game cool they
took it away and now it just kind of
falls in line with every other first
person shooter that we've seen coming
out of you know dice and electronic arts
and it sucks because
this really could have been something
spectacular and it might be
you know they might change it but
it still looks pretty seamless to me
where it's like hey throw up the shield
so you don't get you know shot at you
know spin around the thing do you know
tip the walker over yeah yeah but i
don't i don't want i don't want a
battlefield game with star wars
characters no i won a star wars game
with star wars characters i will tell
you i got really excited when they went
into the at at and the attitude was huge
it was so big it was just appropriately
tall
that was awesome and like i'm so mad at
ea but at the same time i'm like i'm
gonna give you my damn money and i hate
myself for it and now here's the thing
too it's like from the little stuff
we've seen obviously you're gonna get to
play as the rebels obviously there's a
rebel campaign yeah can i can i play as
the real heroes of the story the empire
who brought peace to the universe
yeah the empire the empire brought he
piece of the universe they wiped out
half the universe's population whatever
but yeah they brought peace i'm on joel
scott i love playing the empire in a
battle empire is pretty good that's
where my jam is they're so fancy
been played a million times before like
i want something new i want something
fun and i want something unique and the
star wars battlefront games were that
they were they were unique they were fun
i mean this battlefront literally you
know like you said joel looks like i
could go to nexus mod manager download a
mod for battle for battlefield and play
that and that would be this game
and it sucks you know it's it's
disappointing now again you know maybe i
mean this this is a gameplay reveal
there's some trailers
i'll wait until the reviews come out to
see what people say and to see if this
is really the direction that it takes
but i won't be a day one buyer for
battlefront
you know
i'll wait for the complete edition that
boxes all the dlc that will no doubt be
coming down the line very soon all of it
the the rest of the game um the rest of
the game
so
i knew mortal kombat that's why i didn't
buy the new mortal kombat i'm like new
wait for the complete edition exactly
um dishonored 2 we saw a trailer for
um i never got into the original
dishonored i played it and i mean i
played all the way through i beat it and
i was like i mean this is cool and then
that was that
the world of dishonored is what really
grabbed him like man the world and the
mythology and the lore and this and the
voice cast that was another game that
had like triple a
voice guys it had like susan sarandon
and michael madsen in it
and they they didn't market that at all
you had to actually sit and play the
game like that's michael madison
susan sarandon talking to me right now
and i love the fact that it's evolved to
the point where it's like hey you know
that little girl you protected in the
first one well she's a playable
character now and she's badass too yeah
and the fact that they're actually going
to answer some questions that have been
left hanging from the first game it's
like well who's the magical guy what's
with all the powers what's with
everything else
they might as well call it dishonored 2
all the questions you've been asking
the second half of the game
i like the feel too it looks like
colonial where obviously you know the
first one was all like you know british
imperialness sweet steampunk and now
you're like in this weird caribbean
nation and they're wearing the funny
hats and you know keeping a local
population down so you know
it's colonialism simulator yeah yeah
it'll be fun
um and the last thing that i had on my
notes that i definitely want to talk
about um and it's one of the things i am
almost the most excited for and maybe
you're not that's okay
we got to see doom
yes
holy [ __ ]
let's do it that game is going
that game is going to be
i know i i went to the trailer like
seven times and i was like okay we see
what's clearly going to be imps we see a
revenant we see a pinky if you s if you
pause it at the right time he blasts
fast we see a baron in the background in
the shadows and what could be a cyber
demon right at the end they got they've
got the classics in there for the most
part
i mean it was a cyber deal like when
they had the when when they uh because
are you talking about the
the there was the trailer that used the
one that you're talking about there was
a trailer that i saw where it was like a
minute and a half long and it literally
she was talking about the melding of
machine and you know whatever it was and
it was a cyber demon had the hand cannon
yeah
i'm just excited because the last doom
we had kind of ignored the like the
design of the doom monsters in a sense
and they made their own thing so i'm
really excited to see them take the
old two-dimensional fake 3d graphics and
make them three-dimensional
i like it
i like it because i am now finally going
to be reunited with my first video
gaming love and that is the super shot
guys
right just like oh baby love you so much
as long as i can hold all the weapons
and i don't want to pick two i'm on
board like i'm on board anyway but
i want to see the bfg 3000 come back
i think
it's got like it looks like it was at
the end of the trailer
can i just say i've never played doom so
that's okay
bfg to me means big friendly giant
it means it means big
big effing gun is what it is
yeah
you're going to be killing a lot of
not-so-friendly giants in this game
you're making lots and lots of [ __ ]
and endless horde
i love the level of violence did anyone
ever play bullet storm it reminds me a
lot of bullet storm actually like if
they evolved that to the next level
that's awesome
yeah i'm i'm so jazzed i mean like i
know what we saw was just a trailer
we're not actually seeing levels or
anything like that but from the trailer
even the like idea of the concept levels
that they were coming up with felt like
doom to me like it really still felt
like that you know levels of things
within the level itself going around in
circles trying to get away from things
the only thing we didn't see were actual
space marines being enemies but that's
okay those are i understand those are
probably boring like to them
because they were easy to kill um
is how wonderfully retro the whole thing
felt where it's like wow modern gaming
has not affected doom at all doom is
still pure
in its own weird way it was so pure i'm
like is he gonna pick up a blue key card
is he gonna pick up a blue key card oh
no he cut off someone's arm and that's
the key card even better yeah the game
is still stuck in 1993 no i i think that
and for once that's a good thing yeah
absolutely no i think that that it's
what i'd like to see in truth would be
them basically like like rebooting the
doom series so to speak this is like
year one right here i get not really
year one this is like the first game
right here and then all the games after
that you know it's it's
are gonna be like new games this is
gonna be the whole new doom world that
or i guess the new doom situation
that'll be cool again we won't know i
mean it could just be that like hey like
you're actually in hell now like you're
not on earth anymore so
hey i i just hope that they stick to the
original like history of doom in a sense
you know like that's like there's a
whole lore to it
and if you're into it it's kind of cool
the fact that they're calling it just
doom also makes me think that's what
that is part one of a reboot yeah that
was my thought
um one game that i really want to talk
about that we haven't mentioned and it
was from e3 i think was unraveled oh
yeah yuri
there were plenty of other games that i
hadn't put out there um some mainly
because they weren't as talked about as
much but i know exactly what you're
talking about i watched the trailer for
that and i was like why it's sad it
seems like there are moments in that
trailer i was like oh
it looks sad but it looks so
cute
and it looks like a genuinely good
puzzle platformer which as much as we've
seen good puzzle platformers
from nintendo
everyone else
it's been like this is a platformer kind
of yeah
yeah but it's been mostly like shooting
things
and jumping right
unravel is another yarn based games
essentially but not by nintendo um it
kind of it doesn't necessarily i don't
want to say it has a little big planet
feel
but it sort of does in the sense of it's
like yarn a yarn guy existing in like
like our world and so you're dealing
with these like oversized levels of
things because like that would be what
appeared to them so it it sort of looks
a bit like
thumbelina the yarn
right yeah
um no but i'm really excited for i think
it looks genuinely good i think the
puzzles will actually be genuinely
difficult which you can't say for most
puzzle platformers
absolutely absolutely um are there
anything else that anybody like want to
talk about they heard about from e3
there were a couple there were a couple
games i wanted to run over um okay
the first one was mass effect 4
andromeda andromeda now i am
tease me bioware don't you don't that's
what i'm saying man you know i was i was
sitting you know i was watching the
trailer and i was like okay
i think that like the like the whole of
the gaming community by the whole i mean
like
99.9 of the gaming community can be like
mass effect 3 was awesome
up until the end
and so people were just like this sucks
and so i'm
people are going to buy the heck out of
it it's probably going to be one of the
hottest selling games to come out
but i'm really really hoping that what
we what we get is basically this blend
of mass effect 1 mass effect 2 the first
half of mass effect 3 minus the multiple
endings that you could have had you know
depending on what you did during the
game
and then ultimately you know it they
said it's supposed to be like a new a
new galaxy i think is i think is what
they said it was a whole new world a
whole new galaxy yeah
a whole new apparently
parallel to the events of the original
trilogy so you're just off at another
end of space well shepard
that i didn't know i didn't know that it
was running alongside the time that
shepard's dealing with everything that's
going on so well it's so they can reuse
the reapers or something close to the
reapers but they're called something
else here in this side of the universe
this is like the third age of of mass
effect i don't know if you're like the
third age in the lord of the rings
yeah where like you were just you were
another group of adventurers who just
happened to be adventuring alongside the
actual fellowship and you just did
something else because they don't want
to say commander shepard and his thing
wasn't important
thing they don't want to sweep that with
like okay that was important that was on
the other end of space guys this is a
new end of space oh no i mean if they
did that they said well hey guys this is
mass effect 4 and like at retcons the
first three games like fans are going to
be pissed oh that
what i find interesting about that is
that i think it will show like just how
big the universe is because i think when
you do space games it's easy to kind of
forget that i mean
i i always get irritated when a game is
like you're going to a different planet
and everyone on that planet has the
exact same culture um and they treat the
planet more like a country um
so i think when they do that i it really
shows just how big space is just how
diverse you can get and just how weird
you can get because if you're gonna put
something in space make it weird i want
to see something like cthulhu appear
that's basically what the reapers were
the reapers were basically cthulhu
something weirder than the reapers
though like a real cthulhu like you've
got like a million eyes and everything
where you go insane if you even look at
it like make that the bad guy i don't i
don't know if i want to see like a
lovecraftian horror game
but i just really but i don't want to be
called mass effect how about that
here's my thing do what dragon age
inquisition did for the love of god let
my commander schnepper too whatever
let him be an alien i'm a human i don't
want to role play as a human i i
basically got a lock on humanity or at
least give us the option
yeah just
whatever just put it in there you know
any of you watched um guild grumps uh
game grunts basically played world of
warcraft and they most of them hadn't
played world of warcraft before but
mostly was like hey susie you're a dream
i and aaron you're a dude
he just played a human he was just a
dude you're boring if you play a human
you're super boring if you pick a human
in any fantasy game yeah no it's i i
agree yeah see jake lionheart makes a
good point like a lovecraft game came
out on gamecube it was called eternal
darkness yeah they also made a lovecraft
game called limbo
so
yeah
del toro's been working on a lovecraft
movie forever that okay no no anytime
the word anytime the word
del toro comes up
anything that follows it you have like a
25 chance of it ever actually happening
yeah it's true you know the only movie
of his that i think will happen is the
justice league dog movie but it's not
gonna look like justice league dark it's
gonna be its own thing that's only
because he has like a huge studio who's
gonna be like uh we will destroy you
financially if you don't do this and
they've already changed the name of the
comic to dark universe so maybe he
should hurry
you know what the problem with with
gimble de toro was
is that that people were like i mean
this guy's kind of cool because he made
like like mimic
and like these halfway decent movies and
then he came out with like pan's
labyrinth
and people were just like oh my god he's
like a revolutionary director and he's
the he's he's like a new hell boy yeah
he's like one of the greatest directors
of our time and he's like no
no he's like i'm not shyamalan when he
made the sixth sense like he had one
really awesome okay whoa whoa whoa whoa
we're getting into the territory
write these topics down write them down
when you guys when you guys launch the
movie podcast or whenever we end up
launching the movie podcast when the
weekly cool does like like i want to be
on the first episode it's going to be
it's going to be there's only one topic
per show in that show like that's it
there's not going to be there's going to
be no capabilities to do more than one
you think we get heated about comics
wait till we start talking about movies
man like i've i've seen so many movies
but what
other games what other games are there
so
batman arkham knight yeah
uh
don't
forget you can get
exclusively on the ps4 scarecrow
missions see i like i like how fast way
of being like like rob shut the hell up
is like
slurping his cup on the podcast
like
i didn't say anything
that's false middle finger to me it's
just like it's true but i got it he's
got the next game call um so how do you
guys feel about a arkham knight and b
sony's e3 announcement about scarecrow
missions i think it's funny that it
comes out very soon so they had a whole
trailer that had no batman at all in it
and i don't
oh i'm sorry i'm sorry faust by all
means go ahead good sir
okay the last thing i would want to do
guys don't make me have to institute a
hand raising policy
i'm kind of you would crush me if i
interrupted fast
um no i'm going to put off arkham knight
anyway because they've done that whole
pre-order exclusive dlc thing where you
have to pre-order the game in order to
play part of the game
um
and if any game does that i'm just a bit
like i don't want to pre-order because i
don't know for sure if it's going to be
good
it's a tough pill to swallow that's for
sure no that's absolutely fair yeah it's
it's
i mean the trailer looked amazing from
what i saw like i mean as soon as i saw
that like when the dude was smoking a
cigar i was like okay i thought it might
be the joker because i was waiting for
the joker's eyes to open up you know in
the in the trailer which it didn't
happen and i guess so i guess the
joker's like dead and gone now i guess
he's unless unless through some magic
wouldn't that be amazing if the video
games could keep a character dead for a
while as opposed to
can't
manage to do that
to be fair
they're a comic book game they could
just bring characters back
but it wouldn't be interesting if they
led the way and said no it's okay to let
them be dead for a while it's it's all
right you don't know the clone robot
time is gonna happen like it's gonna
turn out that it wasn't the joker like
the joker like put somebody's body there
or something like that but nonetheless
like
you know when he turned around and like
when he you know blew the smoke into the
guy's face and you know the dude went
all crazy looking i was like okay that's
the scarecrow and that was a really cool
looking scarecrow by the way like that
was a dark sinister twisted screwed up
looking scarecrow and i was like oh my
god it's fear toxin and then as soon as
he started seeing people i was like oh
my god he's shooting everybody in the
restaurant
yeah and they were the guy behind the
scarecrow was coughing so that toxin was
spread so presumably everybody inside
that restaurant started attacking and
killing each other
um having said that
i mean it's called arkham knight or i
guess batman arkham knight so i mean
batman arkham knight batman the dark
knight we know we're gonna see batman in
the game it wouldn't be a batman game
titled a batman game if it didn't have
batman so they'd be weird to call it
like you know batman scarecrow night or
something like that but
um
although honestly i would love to play a
game where you were a schlubby cop in
gotham city trying to solve crimes with
all this craziness happening above you
it'll just be arkham knight the harvey
bullock edition that's exactly what i
was thinking just play around with
playing with whispers
don't play with my heart
it would be it'd be hilarious like
you're just going around like it's like
you have a mission this like just like
go to a donut shop
get booze drink booze drink booze and
then unlocked
i'm just describing like a police
edition of grand theft auto in gotham
no um i i think that i mean it's
see i'm kind of on the fence about
batman games i played batman arkham
asylum and
i actually had i was more entertained
watching other people play it than i was
playing it myself you know i just i
didn't get you know too into it however
you know i haven't played any of the
other new arkham games yet so
i can't really say that the games don't
interest me because you know i haven't
played um
oh god arkham origins i haven't played
you know any of any of those origins is
a little yeah okay that was a bit of a
passion
city's good
i don't know about night though i don't
know it's like it seems like they're
doing a lot of stuff the batmobile's
really cool but at the same time like
you're kind of getting away from batman
though and i and i've heard some rumors
keep it under your hat but i heard some
rumors over at the control breakers
there that uh apparently the game was
supposed to feature
very little batman on foot apparently
the game was supposed to be like 90
batmobile stuff and that's why the game
got pushed back because they had to go
back and add batman stuff to it right
well nobody wants to play a game where
you just ride around like where you
literally just travel from one location
i mean no no no one wants to play batman
you know the batmobile knight that's not
that's not batman like about batman
i can like i recently did a video on the
history of the batmobile thinking it
will be easy to find different
batmobiles in a lot of comics especially
in the 90s the batmobile isn't even
featured
so although the batmobile is important
it's not batman on it's so
it's just an add-on to batman the man
makes the car not the other way around
um yeah all right let's wrap up batman
foust what was the game you wanted to
um final fantasy 14 heaven's ward i
think it's yes it's at e3 um they've got
demos of it uh it comes out next week oh
wow
yeah the game comes out next week
it's an ammo it's an add-on to the mmo
oh okay okay i'm like it's like like a
standalone release like man they cut
that close
it's an expansion to final fantasy 14 i
think there are three new classes but
you have to be at end game to access
anything in it oh interesting
well that's kind of cool because it
forces you to actually play the game as
opposed to just kind of waiting for the
dlc and then
playing that yeah which is cool
i'm excited for it a lot i'm nowhere
near end game out and i think if you
pre-order you get in a week early so
so you'll be in now
yeah you could be in now i think see
today that's that's what pre-orders need
to be like i hate the idea of
pre-ordering and like well you just get
like some skins like if i put a
pre-order a game i like the idea of
getting it before anybody else does i
well i pre-ordered i paired a bioshock
infinite but i got one of the special
ones and i never regretted that because
it had like the little art book with it
and i had like my you know vigor of you
know murder of crows like but that for
me like i like that stuff but only for
certain games and like i was like pretty
sure about that one
man you want to talk about a good game
dude that game was amazing
i pre-ordered animal crossing new leaf
so i could
there's literally a pre-order for
everybody in a sense um yeah talking
about mmo news this is really just not
having to do with e3 necessarily um
blizzard i don't know if anybody heard
this
they're um i believe they're putting out
new areas in one of the expansions and
initially they were like and when you
get there as a high level character you
can't fly
because we want you to explore
we want you to see what we did
then after everyone was like uh
no that sounds like a fussy mother being
like and look what i've done for you
exactly and when everybody like
complained they said you know what
here's no see what we meant was um you
can do a quest
and that will unlock flying and then you
can get a a mount license or something
you know what i mean like it was like
that they're like oh no no no no no no
i love it i love it when they do that
like i love the way you said that like i
love when people when people do that
like they they freak out like microsoft
you know microsoft was like hey guys
here's the xbox one and here's all the
stuff you're not going to be able to do
and people were like what like why am i
going to buy this console now microsoft
was like well
what had happened was yeah and then then
they changed it all up and then suddenly
these features that were impossibly you
know that couldn't be done are suddenly
available now no they're like you must
have we said you can't do that what we
meant was yeah we if you if you guys got
mad enough console is built that way we
can't do it it needs to have the connect
it needs to have all the oh no no
situation just unscrews at the back we
were we were joshing we were josh
exactly
and i know blizzard also has another um
team fortress essentially kind of
looking game coming out as well which i
can never remember the name of it does
anybody remember
anybody rose of the storm of the light
of oh yeah heroes of the storm
what a yeah name what a forgettable
generic name that is
see somebody said they need to have an
alfred spin-off game now i can imagine
like
an alfred spin-off game for batman where
literally all you do
is just like 10 to the house well no no
hang on i got your alfred spin-off game
it takes place when alfred was a
military man and it's what he did then
no i want to i want to i want an
enough game in the house it's gonna be
like cooking mama you gotta
it could be both it could be like him
remembering the days when he was an
actual hero
and now he's no artist one like a
standalone alfred game where it's like
like you have to complete complete
missions like your mission is to like
make bruce wayne's bed
and to put it on the table for when he
gets back
you're gonna get one of these if
dinner's not on the table when bruce
wayne comes home that's bruh
and like look after damian and tim and
make sure they're in on time
hang on what continuity is it gonna take
place in pre-new 52.
well that's going to matter
what time period like will alfred have
to console bruce over the death of jason
todd like
okay yeah do you have to like deal with
that like do you have to consult him
just the right amount to get points to
level him up
i think it should just happen like for
his whole batman career and so you sort
of see
everything from alfred's perspective
okay sounds like a telltale game
telltale could hit that out of the water
right
like jake lionheart had a really good
comment he said he's making bruce some
scrambled eggs and flashes back to burma
how it is that scrambled eggs would make
you flash back to the vietnam war it's
something i don't know
but
the forest down master way
you get to see that moment where alfred
literally with a can of gasoline burns
down the floor see people are putting
all these comments in now like press a
for responsibility
sympathy combo
sympathy points
like uh like j-man has a really good
point like an a la noir
gotham game would be really cool see i
think one of the biggest problems when
it comes to batman games
exactly one of the biggest problems with
the authen games that i have is you're
running around as batman and like you're
just beating up bad guys give me a
batman game like eleanor well you're
literally going around and just solving
crimes like you're you're going i mean
you it's not just like oh my god i gotta
go fight this bad guy and batman you
know gets all the stuff taken care of so
all you have to do is throw some
batarangs and that's it like you've got
to go solve the crimes like move around
the city you got to go find clues in
different parts of the city instead of
just this combine you know this confined
thing i want like an la noir feel so
it's detective comics not just that
exactly
rob were you suggesting a game where
batman is like the world's greatest
detective or something like this
crazy that's what that's what i was
going to say like the batman we know as
comic readers is different from the
batman the general
everyone else knows because they don't
read the comics um and i think that's a
weird situation because when i do my
videos on batman and i'm pretty sure all
of you experience this people always say
why don't you talk more about the fights
and i'm just gonna like because it's a
batman book and you know what they
should do they should put in and look at
this as dlc i'd be okay with this um
where you play a level as and you can do
an unlockable skin and it'll be a change
of voice actor where you play frank
miller's goddamn batman going through
just the most hateful batman ever just
throwing people through winning a little
playtime with that i just want to
experience it and there's even like a
moment where supergirl turns up and goes
hey yeah
you know you know you could do you could
take that infamous scene i don't know if
it was from frank miller's i think it
was from hush where um
bruce wayne was under like and i'm sorry
where superman was under like the
intoxication of poison ivy and so
batman's like okay like if we're gonna
beat superman like let's just kidnap
lois lane and then pretend to drop her
from a building
and then superman will be like oh my god
lois lane he'll snap out of his mind
control and then like he'll be saved and
like you know who
would do the voice for that frank would
want to do the voice acting himself for
the bat yeah
no only i can do it right and that's
fair because only he really understands
why he wrote any of that
green lantern is a punk
that is tiffany that is the perfect
description of frank miller no one
understands why frank miller writes what
he writes except for frank miller and
i'm not even sure frank miller
understands
why he writes some of the stuff that he
writes
i mean i talk to a lot of people like
they admit the dark knight um like books
are really really good but
you don't read them for a good time just
don't
don't feel good summer
yeah
you read it for you know swastika boobs
let's be honest like that's where
everybody's getting it
you read it because everyone says this
is an important batman book that every
batman fan has to eat and you go wow
that was good i'm never doing that again
like i don't want to go to this world
very often
it is it's it's it's it's a descent into
total madness it's like reading it's
like playing silent hill like yeah you
just started innocently enough whoa we
opening that door no we also silently
kill star because we don't want to do
that are you a fan are you a fan of
silent hill i i are you still lamenting
silent hills
all right i'm gonna i'm gonna try to
condense this
game that was cancelled i'm a fan of
silent hill one two and three oh i'm a
fan of kind of
the rest of the american stuff four can
go to hell origins was the closest i got
to a silent hill game and it kind of
sucked yeah silence shattered memories
could just take a long walk off a short
pier and
whoa
homecoming what the hell like
yeah and downpour i started playing it's
at least it's kind of scary but it is
not silent hill and as for pt let's be
honest it's not a silent hill game like
i understand i understand
the genius of what he was going to do
with it i understand how scary it was
but for me it wasn't a silent hill game
so no i'm not lamenting it i was
actually like i'm not excited that i got
cancer because so many people were
excited and actually brought a lot of
people to the silent hill community
but i'm not sad that it's gone
there was a whole here i say i
one and two were the best games those
were the best silent hill games those
were those were these silent hill games
because silent hill was so cool because
it was a psychological thriller it
wasn't a jump scare thriller no exactly
and that's what pt became and that's why
for me i was like this isn't my this
isn't my scion hill but you know what
there's a whole another generation out
there and for them that is like what
they want silent hill to be because
that's what a lot of horror games are
now
the death of silent hill i mean that
just you know foreshadows the death of
horror games in general it's all online
now it's all you know indies and stuff i
had hang on i had like the biggest like
hipster moment but i didn't share it
with anyone i'm going to share it with
you because everyone was like that's it
silent hill is dead and i was like yeah
i thought silent hill was dead when 704
came out and i was like okay i'm just
gonna keep that in here
but now that it's kind of like over i'm
gonna i'm gonna share that with you um
for me like horror games in general the
only horror games i've ever played that
i really really enjoyed were the fatal
well then you're excited too that the
fact that they are they did make the
fatal frame uh wii u game and it
supposedly is coming to america it's not
coming to america it's coming to europe
no they said america too
they said they said maybe america but
definitely and i'm going over there and
i'm gonna make them give it to me
because i am gonna use that damn wii u
mode as a camera in some games who
wasn't i said the pyramid head was a
good guy pyramid had had an impossibly
large sword and he was raping the nurses
um
whatever it was an impossibly large
let's not even start with pyramid head
because pyramid head was
they just they just they just took that
and they were like let's just put it in
everything regardless of storytelling
pyramid head oh god pyramid head was i
mean fighting him was stupid it was just
that it was creepy because you just hear
him dragging that knife around
now for me the moment where like pyramid
head i was like this is a problem it's
pretty much the first time you see him
staying in that hallway and it's just
he's just standing there looking at you
and i'm like
this is this is gonna be a problem
because you're just looking at me you're
literally doing nothing and i am no and
i have to go over there yeah that was my
issue with that game slender i was just
like oh yeah he's a tall guy that that
has no face that just appears makes
things go
okay
no like for me pyramid legitimately
freaked me out and like the concept of
pyramid head the reason that he exists
if you get really into the silent hill
lore like
concept of silent hill 2 in general like
that has a whole other dimension to it
and the fact that they introduce you to
that enemy and he's just standing there
for the very first time like that's
pretty ballsy like he's not doing
anything super menacing except standing
there
like that's cool like that's really cool
what's silent so back to e3
unless anybody has any uh any games they
want to go over i mean i think no i mean
like
there's a lot of again there's a lot of
other titles we didn't mention like
there's a lot of indie games that came
out you know um and you know as much as
e3 is going on right now like for
our purposes e3's a little bit over
because it's like announcements
yeah at this point it's all just like
console updates and yeah whatever in
that case
we're moving on to the final part of the
show which is what have we been playing
this week yeah
rob sorry destiny i've been playing
destiny non-stop yeah i was like wait
why do we even ask rob
okay moving on from rob
oh me um i've been playing the witcher 2
because i want to play the witcher 3 but
i know how story driven it is and i
won't let myself play it the way it's
definitely so good which or two so i've
been enjoying the hell out of that and i
still play hyrule warriors because um
anything that is dinosaur related i will
just throw money at like an idiot
okay uh i have been playing lots of
final fantasy 14 because i will get to
endgame before the expansion comes out
i've only got a little bit left to go
the level the end game is level 50. i'm
level 30 at the moment so
yeah i'm walking
i'm gonna do it
um and then i've also been playing lots
of uh dating sim called dramatical
murder uh if you're not over 18 don't go
and play it
um rob don't play
uh but no i've been enjoying that i i've
finished i think five routes so far so
i've only got about two more endings
left to do nice um
but yeah that's why i've been playing
joel what you got uh i would have liked
to have been player uh playing witcher 3
this month but unfortunately armenian
are going to the montreal comic con in
july in the beginning so i've been
saving all my pennies
which means i couldn't buy the shiny new
game however i was lucky psn had my back
because uh ground zeroes was uh was free
this month and i never played it before
because i wasn't gonna drop full retail
price on what is essentially a glorified
demo so i finally got to play yeah it's
it's fun i'll be honest i got the
witcher 3 for free because i bought a
new pc i had to upgrade so it came with
that so
it's just sitting there taunting me wow
yeah those look like i i'd i would have
popped that game and played it already
i had no person
on console too because i do not have a
beast of a computer unfortunately i
guess at this point what we should do is
bring this show to a close and possibly
do a post show if you guys want we've
talked for like ever since
curiosity
is that chest hair joel
is this oh yes i am a very hairy
gentleman yes i thought so i just i'm a
rugged canadian man i assume you're part
werewolf
part werewolf okay guys um we're going
to we're going to wrap this podcast up
and in the post show we're going to
compare the chest hair of sal
and joel
awesome because something like something
tells me sal has a very hairy chest
um
yeah
he's right it's not quite as much oh
okay well all right guys um anyway
thanks for coming out this is again was
just kind of a test to see how receptive
everybody would be to a gaming podcast
and you guys really seem to love it keep
in mind this is not going to replace the
weekly pool we're not going to get rid
of the comic podcast we were just
thinking about starting another podcast
where we would talk about video games
instead of comics and uh and just kind
of jump into it and see how you guys
thought so um so yeah if you guys are
digging this uh those of you guys will
see this on youtube if you guys enjoy
this concept let us know post a comment
or something like that or just like give
the video a like or something i don't
know i don't know how people normally do
stuff like that i don't know but you
know stuffs i mean
that internet thing that you do to let
people know that you like it and if you
want more they would let us know even if
we didn't ask so let's try
it if you want more gaming and e3
coverage they would crucify me if i
didn't mention it on here comic book has
just recently launched a gaming arm of
itself the control breaker so it used to
be a podcast on our channel now it's a
whole channel of and of itself we were
doing e3 coverage all day yesterday i i
am sick of video games at this point
because
you're right i'm lying i'm lying through
my teeth but you can totally find stuff
there so uh that'd be nice they'd all
like to see you over there
so um so yeah i guess uh we're gonna go
ahead and and this one and we'll catch
you guys later
peace
bye